6 uhr tagwache ist nicht unbedingt meine
zeit aber was tut man nicht alles um an
einen ort zu kommen wo mails
normalerweise nicht hinkommen zur
erstellung und was die jungs da drin
genau treiben da schauen wir uns jetzt
an
herzlich willkommen in stellung wenn
jeder erst die befunde aus
weißt du was du heute hier machst mehr
oder weniger hoffen lässt warum bist du
halt eigentlich das stärkste minus
und wie hast du davon erfahren durch ein
schreiben ist mir die idee kam anders
was verpasst du jetzt ein holzhaus warum
stehst du jetzt da vor dieser tür zum
blutabnehmen schon angst du hast jetzt
da zwei gefäße bekommen für was ist das
es gibt diese shorts in grün und in roth
warum montags haben rot grüne hose
montag mittwoch und am dienstag
donnerstag im rathaus und damit man die
leute aus einander kennen
drinnen umsonst gehört wie groß bin wie
schwer und meldungen volumen zwar trägt
jeder kennt es weniger sein
du hast jetzt bist längere haare muss
man sieht jetzt abschneiden noch eine
vielleicht bonus wirkung also heute
nicht zum umziehen haben die jungs hier
einen eigenen spiel zur verfügung und
zum übernachten gibt es auch ein eigenes
bett da die stellung der zwei tage
dauert es ist ein wunsch gibt es schon
eine richtung waffengattung ich werde
zivildienst machen
also ich bin nicht der waffen mensch ich
würde gern kraftfahrer werden
es würde mich sehr interessieren
vielleicht möchte einfach nur noch
straße kommunales kleines hinter dieser
tür befindet sich unsere nächste station
was wird da jetzt passieren dass du eine
ahnung genau was untersucht wird wir
gehen jetzt einfach mal mit dem miet und
schauen was sich dahinter verbirgt
keine kamera hier ist die ärztliche
untersuchung
was genau passiert denn hinter dieser
tür ja wir sind einfach nur untersucht
worden
es werden fragen über krankheiten in der
familie oder andere chronische krankheit
was man selber hat gestellt
was opfer gedacht während den letzten
paar sekunden
jetzt kommt was dran
der psychiater ist angst was kann
passieren
wann die fragen schwierig da eigentlich
in harte einschnitte deswegen haben wir
bei den beiden darstellungs raum
darstellung somit leichter aber
ansonsten arbeitern logik aufgaben des
weges
sie haben eine frage stellt und computer
und der mann war es bei antworten müssen
hast du geschummelt
wie kann man da schon eine station ist
gerade was gewesen bei der blockade
psychologin
was passiert da ja man kriegt er fragen
stellt bezüglich zum beispiel wieso was
man will
bundesheer oder zivildienst muss bremen
zurzeit ist nichts schlimmes also die
roten schwarz hast du nicht mehr arme
hast deine zivilkleidung an warum die
business mit allem fertig und jetzt geht
es nur mit seiner lösung also wieder
sand untauglich sind
was ist es geworden
deutlich glücklich ja das schon und das
ermöglicht es patienten kommen kann
wie geht es weiter bei dir jetzt gehts
wehrdienstberatung
der tag ist so gut wie vorüber wie ist
ergangen
eigentlich ja mal was ganz was anderes
mal durchchecken lassen
sie soll es recht flott hero eigentlich
alles menschliche post was mich aber
noch brennend interessiert ist der
psychologische tests und den mache ich
jetzt doch die fragen die bleiben mein
geheimnis